China is building a fortress against
coronavirus one that extends beyond its
borders earlier this week the Chinese
government announced it would ban all
foreigners from entering in 24 hours
time we raced to get from Seoul in South
Korea back home to Beijing your
temperature has to be below 37 degrees
to board and they keep checking flying
to another country is now like traveling
to another reality
these aren't health workers their cabin
crew another temperature check
mid-flight
we landed in Dalian in northeast China
customs officials also in full
protective gear checked every passenger
[Music]
here at the ramparts an army of
officials in full medical armor an
outlying fortification to make sure the
capital Beijing hundreds of miles away
is kept safe every passenger was tested
for covert 19 including our producer
Michael Greenfield
swabbing the back of the throat then the
back of the nose it is as uncomfortable
as it looks
we made it onto Chinese soil for hours
before the ban on foreigners came into
effect so we made it into town about
three hours before the deadline for
foreigners getting in as a pretty
comprehensive process when you do arrive
here first on the plane there are checks
temperature checks and then everyone
goes off the plane has a health
interview and then you're given a covert
test yourself a swab in the back of the
throat up the nose my eyes might have
watered a little now we're waiting to
hopefully reboard the flight back to
Beijing and people don't have symptoms
I've got a seat number here that was my
seat on the plane this is where I'm
sitting everyone's being told to sit
apart we've been given a meal but they
are taking this extremely serious is a
very very thorough quiet actually an
impressive process
but we would not be going to Beijing a
new policy instead we were bused to a
local hotel requisitioned by the Chinese
state where we'd be quarantined for two
weeks we queued according to the
markings for social distance and paid
for our rooms the rate included meals
delivered three times a day left outside
our door so this is it's 340 RMB per
night it's about just under 40 pounds
and it is home for the next 14 days the
next day our covert 19 tests came back
negative in action and cover-up marred
China's response to the outbreak inside
its borders now the virus is a foreign
menace they'll go to every length to
keep it at bay
Tom Cheshire Sky News Dalian